This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. There's an iconic episode of the TV show Seinfeld where the character George muses about a woman who treated him poorly. She took advantage of his romantic interest in her, treated him like trash, and then discarded him. George begins fantasizing to his friend Jerry Seinfeld about what he would tell the woman if he met her again. He would remind her of all the ways she treated him like dirt.
He would stand up for himself. He would insist that she respect his dignity and apologize. Since this is comedy, George of course runs into the woman shortly thereafter at a social gathering. Instead of being brave and forthright, he is meek and obsequious. He allows her to run right over him all over again. But in that same scene, another woman comes up to Jerry Seinfeld. She went on a date with him long ago, and she felt he did not treat her well.
She tells him what George had meant to say. Remember me? I'm sorry. Mary Cantardi? No? Doesn't ring a bell, Jerry? We had a date three years ago. You said you'd call me the next day. Well, I'm sure I meant to call.
I probably just lost... Liar! Liar! You were never going to call me! You thought you could waltz through the rest of your life and never bump into me again, but you were wrong, Jerry, you were wrong. Last week on the show, we examined the science of conversation. We looked at why an ordinary chat is far from ordinary.
These interactions involve hundreds of micro-decisions and a delicate dance of coordination. If you missed that episode, I would urge you to listen to it first. You can find it in this podcast feed. It's called We Need to Talk. Today we look at the conversations we all dread, telling someone they treated us poorly, demanding a raise, taking away an elderly relative's car keys. We look at what makes difficult conversations difficult and a series of psychological techniques to help you navigate them. How to have difficult conversations this week on Hidden Brain.
Is there a conversation you need to have that you keep putting off? In your head, do you play out this conversation, and in every telling, does it end in hurt feelings, misunderstandings, and unhappiness? Allison Woodbrooks is a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School. She studies the art and science of conversations and how we can get better at having difficult conversations. Allison Woodbrooks, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Allison, one way we mishandle difficult conversations is that we avoid having them altogether.
How common is such evasion? Avoidance is so common. And it's common in my life, too. I'm an avoider, and so I deeply understand why so many people avoid having hard conversations. They avoid people that they know will be hard to interact with and they avoid topics that feel at least ahead of time like they're going to be very difficult for any number of reasons. You know I remember many years ago as a small child my grandfather you know had rented out an apartment to someone and that person wasn't paying my grandfather the rent.
And my grandfather knew he had to have a conversation with a tenant and basically it was going to be a difficult conversation. And he was a people pleaser and he hated having difficult conversations. So whenever he saw the tenant come up the other side of the road, he would run and hide in the bushes because he didn't want to have the difficult conversation with the tenant come up the other side of the road, he would run and hide in the bushes because he didn't want to have the difficult conversation with the tenant. And of course, as a small child, you look at that and you realize, oh, these are difficult conversations.
One way to handle them is to basically not have them at all. That's right. That's right. And it's not always the wrong instinct, but you do have to sort of think about who is it leading us to avoid and why? Why are we avoiding these topics? And are those reasons good? Are they biased?
Are they preventing us from having a deeper relationship? Can you think of a conversation that you need to have with another person that you've been putting off, Allison? So many. I feel like I avoid certain topics often. Right now, maybe just today. I mean, I could initiate conversations with many of my students, for example, and tell them that I don't think that their performance in the course so far has been terrific, and that I'm disappointed in them, and that I think it's not only going to affect their
grade, but their learning and also how I personally feel about them, right? Like, it's not only going to affect their grade, but their learning and also how I personally feel about them, right? It's affecting our relationship in a sort of personal way. The way I avoid that conversation is by asking my assistant to write emails to the students and just let them know what assignments they're missing. Rather than starting a conversation with 20 different people that I think will be hurtful or unpleasant or hard or time consuming or make them feel bad. There's so many reasons that prevent me
from sort of reaching out one-on-one to them. one-on-one to them. You know it's interesting Alison, you know many of us think when we are subordinates or students or in a position where someone else has power over us that the the manager or the supervisor or the administrator has no problem whatsoever telling us what they think and feel because of course this person has all this power. We build them up to have all this power in our mind. But I think what you're saying is that this actually runs both ways.
from so-called reaching out one-on-one to them. one-on-one to them. You know it's interesting Alison, you know many of us think when we are subordinates or students or in a position where someone else has power over us that the the manager or the supervisor or the administrator has no problem whatsoever telling us what they think and feel because of course this person has all this power. We build them up to have all this power in our mind. But I think what you're saying is that this actually runs both ways.
Your students might understandably have trepidation coming to you and discussing something difficult with you, but you have the same problem discussing it with them. That's right. It's a profound human instinct to try to avoid unpleasantness or things that you don't think will go well. And often that unpleasantness comes from us grappling with this feeling torn between honesty and being kind. And that really has nothing to do with status, right,
if we're grappling with, can I tell you the truth and is that going to be hurtful to you? So in 2013, you're taught a negotiation class about a fictional football quarterback named AJ Washington. You were a relatively new professor and you worked hard to make your presentation engaging. You even had planned a big reveal at the end of the presentation. Can you describe what happened that day? Shankar, I was so excited about this day in class. It was a case about a fictionalized quarterback in the NFL named A.J. Washington.
And it had been written actually about Tom Brady, our famed Boston New England Patriots quarterback and his negotiation over his salary and his player contract. So there's a big reveal at the end of class where I reveal that this whole case has been about Tom Brady the whole time. And I had brought a very important prop to class to share with the students at the end of this case discussion. And it was on loan to me from my dear colleague, who had been the chief operating officer of the New England Patriots for a very long time. And he let me bring one of his Super Bowl rings to class. Wow. To help with this big reveal about Tom Brady.
And I was so excited and I made this big show of it. At the end, I sort of lifted it up in the air and I knelt down and all the students erupted in applause. And they all came down at the end of class and wanted to take photos with the Super Bowl ring and it was so fun. I was very early in my career at the business school and I was like, oh man, I am nailing this. I am an amazing teacher.
This is going so good. Couldn't be going better. But a few days later, I got an email, as I so often do from students, asking to meet with me. And this student comes to my office and I have so many meetings with students and the topics are all over the map. But I thought that he would be asking about a job that he'd applied for, some personal problem that he was coping with.
Instead, he sort of sat down and said, I love the class, it's going so great, thank you so much, there's just one thing, there's just one thing that I want to talk to you about. And I was like, oh no, geez. And he said, do you remember in class when you flashed the photo of Tom Brady up on your slides? I said, oh yeah, that was awesome, wasn't it? And he said, yes, but you said, you paused on this slide and you said, hey ladies, enjoy the view. And I said, oh yeah, I remember that. I was going for this big dramatic effect. And he said, you know, framing it that way felt really heteronormative. And this was a long time ago.
This was probably 2013. I don't think I had ever heard the word heteronormative before. And I said, oh my goodness, tell me more. What do you mean? And he said, well, it kind of felt like you were only talking to the people who are heterosexual, only people who
are interested in the opposite gender in the class. What about all the male students who wanted to enjoy the view? It's worth pausing for a moment and asking how you would have responded in this situation. You're a teacher, and you've just put in a lot of thought and effort into creating a great presentation. A student is upset because of a phrase you used. Would you dismiss the student as being overly sensitive? Too woke? Would you even listen? The point here is not what you would have actually done, but
to illustrate what happens when we are confronted by difficult conversations. Very often, the conversation inside our heads can get so loud that we stop paying attention to the conversation inside our heads can get so loud that we stop paying attention to the conversation outside. Allison did not tune out the student. I thought, whoa, whoa, you're right, for sure. I definitely was coming from the sort of heteronormative perspective. And I couldn't have imagined that such a sort of,
a moment of levity could be experienced in that way as sort of exclusionary. And I was really disappointed in myself. I was really, I was in my 20s still. I was really young as a professor. And I thought, gosh, of all of the faculty here, the young woman is the one who's getting this wrong and I'm so sorry, like I really I want to be the inclusive one.
And then he said, the sort of saddest part of all, he said, well, most professors make me feel this way. You're just the only one that I feel comfortable enough sharing it with." And I thought, oh my goodness, I guess that's good for me, but so bad for us collectively in terms of sort of conversational safety and the ability to have these hard conversations. hard conversations. So there's so much going on in that story, Alison. And as you're telling the story and putting myself in your shoes, sitting across from the student,
the student basically says, effectively, you were being insensitive when you made this joke in class. And I can imagine you, you know, at that moment sort of tensing up and sort of getting a little anxious and getting a little worried and feeling a little aroused. You know, there's a spotlight being trained on you and you are being called out as someone who is, you know, an unkind and sensitive person. That's right. And we all feel these moments and there are these fleeting moments where
you have high arousal and negative feelings. There's a map that scholars call the affective circumplex but my students like to call it the wheel of feelings. And it's sort of high to low arousal on the y-axis and then negative to positive on the x-axis. And that upper left quadrant is this high arousal, negative feelings, anger, defensiveness, anxiety. Your heart starts to race. You're feeling bad. And these feelings happen in conversation when something starts to not feel right.
And it's a familiar feeling. And that's a familiar feeling. And that's definitely how I was feeling in that moment, this arousal, my heart's racing, probably your stress hormones are to release in your body. And there are a number of ways that you can react to it. And I think we all grapple with, well, should I react defensively?
Should I react angrily? Do I have the sort of self-control to continue engaging in this conversation in a way that's reasonable and productive? And I mean, I think the student did a very smart thing by coming and talking to you in the privacy of her office, because in some ways now, you're having a one-on-one conversation. If the student had brought this up in the class, for example, that could have made you feel even more defensive and even more put on the spot. In the class or online, on social media,
we see this happen all the time. In my mind, really, it's very rare to feel like any topic is too sensitive to discuss, but there are so many contexts that are too sensitive. I sometimes wonder, is there such a thing as a sensitive topic or is it all just sensitive contexts? And so it was so kind that the student came and met one-on-one and also that they started the conversation by being so complimentary and saying, hey, I really love this class.
I think you're doing such an amazing job teaching us. And it's because I feel so comfortable with you that I feel safe sharing this constructive feedback about this one moment. ["The Most Important Lesson to Learn When You Are Engaged"] When we come back, the single most important lesson to learn when you are engaged in a difficult conversation. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Think back to the last time you had a difficult conversation.
Maybe it was with a manager or an employee. Maybe it was with a partner or a parent. What did it feel like in the moments before you had the conversation? Did you feel yourself getting tense? Did you feel the need to get a drink first or to avoid the conversation altogether? At Harvard Business School, behavioral scientist Alison Woodbrook says that handling difficult conversations starts with noticing how we respond to them. You
cannot be an effective interlocutor with someone else when you are unaware of how you yourself are reacting. Allison got a chance to apply her research in her own life when a student came to her and complained that she had been insensitive in class. It's recognizing your own emotions. It's also trying to recognize what your goals are in that moment. So emotions are often automatic and you get into that upper left quadrant, those high arousal negative feelings, and there are these sort of parasympathetic nervous system
signals that are happening that you can't control. But reflecting about what your goals are is so important. Are you trying to persuade other people to agree with you? Are you trying to continue to engage in this conversation? Are you trying to connect? Are you trying to learn from them? Are you trying to listen? What we've found in much of our research
is that in these moments, when you're feeling these high arousal negative feelings, it's very natural to have goals to defend yourself and to persuade other people to agree with you. Like, you need to understand me. So you start making statements to try and persuade them. But the more effective way to react in those moments is to focus on learning, which is not intuitive.
So you need to learn as much as you can about the other person's perspective. Why are they, why did they feel this way? So you need to learn as much as you can about the other person's perspective. Why did they feel this way? He clearly felt moved enough that he needed to come and give me this feedback. Tell me more about that. What was that like for you and how often do you feel this way and how could I have said this differently? So learning as much as you can about the other person's perspective
is much more effective for making the conversation continue in a productive way and ultimately, and this is sort of the ironic part, ultimately to be more persuasive because the other person is going to see you as much more reasonable and measured. I mean, in some ways, this is such a profound insight, Allison, because when I think about the difficult conversations either that I've had or that I need to have, I do think I have approached those conversations with a mindset of how do I convince this other person about this thing that I know is right? I know it's right, they don't know it's right, my job is to persuade them that in some ways they are wrong.
And in some ways you're saying that is the wrong way to go about it, that the approach, the orientation of persuasion in some ways sets us on the wrong track when it comes to having these difficult conversations. That's right. And you're not alone. Almost everyone has that instinct. It's a deeply held human instinct to feel like you're right and you want to persuade other people to see your point of view and to persuade them to agree with you.
It's just not an effective mindset or effective behaviors in the context of a live unfolding dialogue because it's impossible, it's so difficult to be on the receiving end of that, that it's hard to continue to listen and engage in the ways that you need to to even keep a conversation going. ["The Secret of the Heart"]
So, some time ago, Alison, we featured your colleague Julia Minson on Hidden Brain. She has studied the effects of something called conversational receptiveness, which is closely linked to this idea of turning a difficult conversation from an exercise in persuasion to an exercise in learning. What is conversational receptiveness, Allison? Julie Minson's work, Hannah Collins, Mikey Omens, this work is incredible and groundbreaking on receptiveness. They define receptiveness, especially in conversation, as openness to opposing viewpoints. And the ability to engage receptively live in a live conversation is an incredible skill that we can all work on and is counterintuitive to most people.
Can you talk about some of the elements of conversational receptiveness? Julia Menson and others talk about starting with the role of acknowledgement, that to actually acknowledge what it is that the other person is saying to you. That's right, and acknowledgement is a very simple thing. It's almost like just repeating back what you've heard from someone. I hear you saying this, right? Is that correct? I hear you asking this question about receptiveness, Shankar. Am I hearing you right? It's sort of this acknowledgement of like, I'm listening to you and I'm understanding what you're saying. The sort of next bump up from acknowledgement is affirmation.
So you take what another person has said and you attach a positive affirmation to it. So I say, I hear what you're saying and also I appreciate it. It makes sense that you would feel that way about this thing. That's great. You're such a reasonable person. So this sort of affirmation, I love how you said, I love how you asked this question.
It's a great one. And so you attach this positive attribution and affirmation onto your acknowledgement. Now all of this is completely independent from agreement, right? You are not necessarily going to go on and agree with what they've said. They're just making the point that linguistically, it's so important to start from a place of saying, I hear what you're saying, I understand it, I like it, I think it's reasonable that you feel that way, tell me more about it, and just maintaining a tone that your partner is going to be able to continue to engage with, whether you go on to agree or disagree later in the
conversation. Another way to think of it would be like validation. You need to validate their feelings, even if you're not going to agree with their beliefs. One of the things that we often do when we're having difficult conversations is that we fixate on the areas of disagreement that we have with someone else. And that's understandable. That's what makes a difficult conversation difficult. But what are we missing when we do that, Allison? It's wild. This has been very eye-opening for me. When you're in a conversation, as soon as you stumble across even any sort of difference, when you realize, oh, this person feels differently than me,
or they have a belief that's different than mine, or they have a piece of their identity that's very different, it's our instinct is to focus so strongly on that disagreement or that difference that we almost completely forget about the 99% of other things that we have in common and agree about. I mean, really, like everyone wants to feel loved. Everyone wants to feel safe. Everyone wants to feel adored and admired. Everyone likes ice cream.
Everybody likes being in a warm room, right? Like there's so many things that we all agree about and for whatever reason, all of those things sort of go out the window and we fixate on these little moments of disagreement and difference. Yeah, and this is not to say that the areas of disagreement are not real, they are real, but it may be that it's actually 15% of the
painting as opposed to 85% of the painting. That's right. And we forget about the rest of the painting. One of the other ideas that Julia Mintzen and others talk about is that when we are proposing our ideas, so when it's our turn to speak, to hedge those ideas a little bit, to not speak in overly declarative language or confident language, to basically say, I think, or hear something to think about. What does that do in a difficult conversation, Allison? It goes back to this idea of our instinct says to that I'm right and I'm gonna prove to you that I'm right and to do that I need to say it in such a compelling and strong way that you can't possibly deny that I'm right. We forget that it's really hard to be on the receiving end of that, to be the listener and to be receiving such like strong statement, righteous sort of language.
And so this point about qualifying your language, expressing the points that you're uncertain about, like I actually was wondering if this or I think I'm pretty sure this or I wonder about this, those qualifications, that qualifying language goes against our instincts to be strong and resolute and decisive. But being on the receiving end of it makes that person sound so much more reasonable and realistic, and it's so much easier to engage with them. So you're probably detecting a theme here, which is all of this stuff goes towards the goal of being able to continue talking to each other in a way that's productive
and, dare I say, enjoyable. Because if we go along with our instincts to prove to people that we're right, it's very hard to continue to have that conversation and it's going to spiral into a place that's not enjoyable You know, I was talking to another guest on hidden brain some time ago and and he used to be a champion You know debater in in high school And of course, when you're having a debate, you present your strongest argument and the other person presents their strongest argument, and then a judge decides whose argument is the best. And he was pointing out that in many ways, we conduct difficult conversations the same way, which is we try and prosecute our argument and expect the other person is going to prosecute their argument.
And then imagine that there is some kind of imaginary judge who's going to come in and give us the prize for coming up with the better argument. But of course, in real life, there is no judge, there is no third party to adjudicate and say your argument was better than the other person's argument. Your goal, in fact, is to get across to the other person and to sort of find common ground with the other person. And that's very hard to do when you're trying to beat the other person into a pulp. That's exactly right. And there's this sort of thought experiment that I like to do that I think of as my way, your way, the right way. For almost any task or any topic or any issue, let's just call it loading the dishwasher.
I have my way of loading the dishwasher, you have your way of loading the dishwasher, but probably neither of our ways of loading the dishwasher is the objectively correct or optimal way of loading the dishwasher. And so, nitpicking with each other and arguing about, well, my way is the best way, and then you say, well, my way is the best way. It's all so silly, especially when neither of you knows the sort of ground truth objective reality of what's the best way. When the emotions we're feeling are unhelpfully negative, you say, Alison, that we should reframe them in a more positive light. Can you explain what you mean by that? What do you mean by reframing a negative emotion in a positive light?
When we feel negative emotions, which we all do a lot of the time, we have a lot more control over how we experience that emotion than we would think. So I'll give the example of anxiety. When we feel anxious, it's a high arousal emotion, it's very negative. Our instinct tells us to try and calm down, try and get rid of that emotion. People go to great lengths to try and calm down when they're feeling anxious. But calming down requires a sort of two-step move. You have to reduce your physiological arousal, so your racing heart, your sweaty palms, your
cortisol in your body. Those things are really hard to control. You actually don't have a lot of executive control over those things. And you're trying to move from negative emotion to positive. So it's this two-step thing that turns out very hard to do, if not impossible. The idea of reframing is let's focus on the part of it that we do have more control over, and that's our appraisal of negative versus positive.
So if you're feeling anxious, what if we stay in high arousal world and you just say to yourself, you know what, I'm excited. Just that small flip helps move you from negative valence anxiety to positive valence excitement. So you can see, for example, distress as passion, for example, as a way of reframing or reappraising the distress that you're experiencing.
That's exactly right. So I have worked with Lizzie Bailey Wolf about this. Often people say, I'm stressed, I'm so distressed. But you can reframe that for your own benefit and saying, no, no, this is just a signal that I care about it, that I'm passionate. And actually saying it out loud is really compelling to the people around you as well.
So in some ways what I understand you saying, Alison, is that the goal here is not so much to change the emotion itself, but to shift your interpretation of the emotion. That's right. Psychologists call this reappraisal. You're shifting the appraisal, not how you're feeling it physiologically, but just how you're thinking about and interpreting that feeling. You have a colleague, Cynthia,
who has a very effective way of reframing emotion when a discussion gets too heated. What is her technique, Allison? My colleague Cynthia is amazing. She's an incredible teacher, and I love watching her teach because she constantly keeps her sort of hand on the dial, the sort of temperature knob of the mood of the classroom. And when she feels like things are getting too down or sad or angry, she calls it out. She says, I'm not loving the emotional vibe in here,
let's hit the refresh button. And she does, even just by labeling it and saying, let's hit the refresh button, it really helps so much. So in other words, just like we can call attention to what's happening inside our minds and label it and say, you know, I'm feeling defensive. I'm feeling upset. I'm feeling called out. I'm feeling threatened.
What she is doing is saying we can call attention to what's happening in the conversation. Notice where we are in the chat. That's right. It's what makes levity so powerful as well. You notice if people are getting bored or disengaged from the conversation. It's so important in those moments to realize the emotional timbre and to do something about it. Switch topics, make a joke, smile, give someone a compliment. Just to lift the mood is incredibly powerful. One error we make in difficult conversations is we sometimes try to see things from the
perspective of the other person, which on the surface seems like a good thing. But the problem is when we do this, we imagine how we would think and what we would do in their circumstances. Talk about what happens when we do this, Allison. It's such a well-meaning instinct, but unfortunately the human mind is so egocentric. So we try to imagine what another person would be thinking and feeling, but we use our own thoughts and feelings as a sort of proxy, as a guess. This is what helps us guess how other people are thinking and feeling. We're relying on our own point of view. And unfortunately, no two people are exactly alike. Even my twin sister Sarah and I are not exactly alike.
设身处地为他人着想，表面上看似乎是一件好事。但问题在于，当我们这样做时，我们想象的是自己在那种情况下会怎么想、会怎么做。艾莉森，跟我们聊聊当我们这样做时会发生什么。这是一种充满善意的直觉，但不幸的是，人类的大脑是非常以自我为中心的。因此，我们试图去想象另一个人在想什么、感受什么，但我们却把自己的思想和感受当作一种代理或猜测。正是这一点在帮助我们去猜度别人的想法和感受。我们依赖的是自己的观点。而不幸的是，没有哪两个人是完全一样的。就连我和我的双胞胎妹妹莎拉也不是完全一样的。
And most people are just incredibly different from each other. And we underestimate how different other people are from us. So very famously, psychologists have found that people are just really, it's very challenging to take another person's perspective. The most direct way to take another person's perspective isn't to guess, but to ask them for it, to ask questions and actually hear from their own mouth what's going on in their mind. When we come back, why seemingly innocuous comments can deeply hurt another person and a magic key to disarming someone who is very angry with you.
而且大多数人彼此之间有着巨大的差异。我们往往低估了别人与我们的不同之处。因此，众所周知，心理学家发现人们很难真正站在他人的角度思考问题。设身处地为人着想的最直接方法不是去猜测，而是直接问他们，提出问题，并亲耳倾听他们脑海中究竟在想什么。稍后我们回来，探讨为什么看似无害的评论会深深伤害他人，以及化解对你满腔怒火之人的神奇钥匙。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you ever noticed that when you're having a difficult conversation, or even a conversation that wasn't supposed to be difficult, something you say can set off another person and send the conversation haywire? You are not trying to give offense but the other person is deeply offended. At Harvard Business School, Allison Woodbrook says she teaches her students an exercise to avoid such landmines. My students find it helpful to use a model
欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你有没有注意到，当你在进行一场艰难的对话，甚至是一场本不该艰难的对话时，你所说的话却可能会激怒对方，让对话彻底失控？你本无意冒犯，但对方却感到了深深的冒犯。哈佛商学院的艾莉森·伍德布鲁克斯表示，她会教给学生一个练习来避开这些雷区。我的学生们发现，使用一个模型非常有用
to think about why these difficult moments pop up in conversations, sometimes unexpectedly, often unexpectedly, and we use a model that we call the layers of the earth. Above the surface of the earth, this is the content of the conversation, so the words that we're saying to each other, the sound, the way we sound to each other are nonverbal cues.
来思考为什么这些困难时刻会出现在对话中，有时是出乎意料的，往往也是意料之外的。我们使用了一个被称为地球分层的模型。在地球表面之上，这是对话的内容，也就是我们对彼此说的话、声音，以及我们给彼此传达的声音中的非言语线索。
All the things that are observable above the surface. Right at the surface of the earth are our emotions, and sometimes parts of our emotions are observable. You can tell when I'm getting angry or anxious or upset, and sometimes they're hidden beneath the surface of the earth. Right below that layer are our motives or our goals. Maybe sometimes I want to seek your advice, but you don't want to give it. Or I want to persuade you, but you are not ready to be persuaded. When we have incongruous motives, it's another way that difficult moments can erupt. And then at the very core of the earth, of course, are our differences in our
所有在地面上可观察到的事物。就在地表之上的是我们的情绪，有时我们的一部分情绪是可以被观察到的。你可以看出我什么时候变得生气、焦虑或心烦意乱，而有时它们则隐藏在地球表面之下。紧挨着那一层的是我们的动机或目标。也许有时我想征求你的意见，但你不想给。或者我想说服你，但你还没准备好接受说服。当我们存在不一致的动机时，这是困难时刻爆发的另一种方式。然后，当然，在地球的最核心处，则是我们
identities. And anytime conversation shoots down to the hot magma of our identity, things are going to feel really hot and heated and difficult. And even sort of easy conversations have a way of shooting down to that hot magma core of our identities in sort of unexpected ways. My students talk about this a lot. Like, you know, you can even an innocuous question like, oh, where did you get your glasses or hey, I love your haircut, can feel sort of deeply threatening to people if they're imagining that this question is going to lead to something very sensitive about their identity
身份的差异。每当对话直奔我们身份的炽热岩浆时，事情就会变得非常灼热、激烈和困难。甚至一些看似轻松的对话，也会以某种意想不到的方式直奔我们身份那炽热的岩浆核心。我的学生们经常讨论这个。比如，你知道，甚至一个无害的问题，比如“哦，你的眼镜是在哪买的？”或者“嘿，我喜欢你的发型”，如果人们想象这个问题会引出关于他们身份的非常敏感的话题，就会让人觉得这是一种深深的威胁
or where they're from or their race or their gender or their sexual orientation. And so what we talk about in my class is becoming a little bit more aware of differences at every layer of the earth. So at the surface where our words, are we literally using the same, the right words? Are we understanding each other and what we mean when we're using certain words? And often moments of difficulty come from like, oh, we're just misunderstanding each other.
或是关于他们的出身、种族、性别或性取向。因此，我们在课堂上探讨的是，要对地球每一层的差异有更多的觉察。所以在表层，也就是我们的字词上，我们使用的字词真的完全一样且正确吗？我们在使用某些词时，是否理解了彼此的意思？通常，困难时刻的产生是因为“哦，我们只是互相误解了”。
We're using the same word to mean different things or we're not talking about the same thing. Often these differences in our emotions cause problems. I want to go have fun. You actually want to have a deep conversation. We have different motives, and then of course differences in our identities. And I think most of the most difficult moments in conversation come from the moments when you poke an invisible barb into somebody's identity.
我们用相同的词来表达不同的意思，或者我们谈论的根本不是同一件事。通常，这些情绪上的差异会导致问题。我想去玩。而你其实想进行一场深刻的对话。我们有不同的动机，然后当然还有身份上的差异。我认为，对话中最困难的时刻，大多源于你无意中触碰了某人身份上的一根隐形倒刺。
And sometimes you realize when it's happened and sometimes you don't. It goes back to the story of this LGBTQ student who came and talked to me about making an insensitive comment, a heteronormative comment in class. I poked an invisible barb into an important part of who he is, and he didn't feel seen and acknowledged and valued and worthy of care.
有时你意识到它发生了，有时则没有。这就回到了那个LGBTQ学生的的故事，他来找我谈论在课堂上发表不敏感言论、异性恋规范言论的事。我在他身份的重要部分扎了一根隐形倒刺，而他没有感到被看见、被认可、被珍视以及值得被关怀。
And so anytime that we make our conversation partner feel like we don't understand them, we don't see them, and we are not making them feel worthy of care, it's going to cause problems. When you were a college student, Allison, you and your fellow students found yourselves in opposition to an administrator. The students saw this administrator as an enforcer and they thought that she was heavy-handed. They often clashed with her. You decided to try another approach. Can you tell me what happened? So, I was a member of a club, a social club, when I was an undergrad. And there was a woman there whose full-time job it was to take care of this beautiful property and to keep all
因此，每当我们让谈话对象觉得我们不理解他们、看不见他们，并且没有让他们感受到自己值得被关怀时，就会引发问题。艾莉森，当你还是个大学生时，你和你的同学们发现自己与一位行政人员对立。学生们把这位行政人员视为执法者，认为她专横跋扈。你们经常与她发生冲突。你决定尝试另一种方法。能告诉我发生了什么吗？当时，我是一名俱乐部成员，在我读本科时是一个社交俱乐部。那里有一位女性，她的全职工作就是照顾这处美丽的物业，并保护所有
the students who hung out there and ate their meals there to keep them safe. And historically, the student members of the club had this really confrontational sort of oppositional relationship with this house manager. And I remember watching this oppositional dynamic unfold and it really made me feel not only uncomfortable, but also I started to feel like this isn't serving the students well either because it puts her in this enforcer position, in this oppositional position. She's not going to give us the things that we want. And so I, I, I, when I became the sort of vice president of this club, I, I thought I I'm gonna try and convince my fellow students,
在那里闲逛、在那里用餐的学生们的安全。历史上，俱乐部的学生会员与这位宿舍管理员一直有一种非常对抗性的、对立的关系。我记得看着这种对立动态的上演，这不仅让我感到不舒服，而且我也开始觉得这对于学生们来说也没有好处，因为它把她置于执法者的位置、对立的位置。她不会给我们想要的东西。所以，当我成为这个俱乐部的副主席时，我想试着说服我的同学们，
the fellow leaders of the club, and this woman, let's reposition ourselves as allies. Like, why don't we try and work together? And so first I had to convince the other students that this was a good approach. That was not easy because there was a lot of animosity between the students and this house manager. But then the really hard conversation
俱乐部的其他领导者以及这位女士，让我们重新定位自己为盟友。比如，为什么我们不尝试一起合作呢？所以首先我必须说服其他学生这是一个好方法。这并不容易，因为学生和这位宿舍管理员之间存在着很多敌意。但随后那场真正艰难的对话
was facing this woman myself. And I remember it very vividly. It was in her office, in private, sort of woman on woman. I was the first woman who had ever been an officer in this club. And I went and met with her one-on-one and she was so gracious and so grateful when I apologized for the behavior of all the students historically and how unkind they had been and why this animosity had erupted between
是亲自面对这位女士。我至今记忆犹新。那是在她的办公室里，私下进行的，可以说是女性对女性的交流。我是这个俱乐部历史上第一位女性干事。我单独去见了她，而当我为学生们历来的行为、他们的不友善，以及为什么这种敌意会在
the students and this house manager. I just said, I'm so sorry, like, we don't want you to feel that way. We want to work together. We want to be on the same team here. And she just said, thank you so much. Thank you so much for saying this. It sounds so amazing. And we both cried and she was so grateful. And it really felt like this turning point in the dynamic, which did prove out to be really great for us going forward. It really worked out well. She gave the club so much more of what we actually wanted. And then what was really moving, it ended up being one of the most meaningful sort of
学生与宿舍管理员之间爆发进行道歉时，她是那么的亲切和感激。我只是说，我真的很抱歉，我们不希望你觉得难受。我们想一起合作。我们想成为同一个团队。而她只是说，非常感谢你。非常感谢你说出这些。这听起来太美妙了。我们都哭了，她是那样的感激。这真的感觉像是动态上的一个转折点，事实证明，这对我们未来的发展确实非常好。结果真的很棒。她给了俱乐部更多我们真正想要的东西。然后，真正感人的是，它最终成为了我人生中最有意义的
conversations of my life. That was, you know, 15 years ago. And that was an inflection point for the club going forward. The students then developed a new norm of being friends with this woman and being on good terms and it continued on for the next 15 years. And I saw her at my 15th college reunion and she looked great. She looked so healthy and happy, and she pulled me aside, and she said, I just can never thank you enough for having that conversation with me and making this change. It changed the club for the better, and it changed my life. And it meant so much
对话之一。那是15年前的事了。那是俱乐部未来发展的一个转折点。学生们随后形成了一种新常态，那就是与这位女士做朋友并保持良好关系，这种关系在接下来的15年里一直延续下去。我在大学毕业15周年聚会上见到了她，她看起来状态极佳。她看起来那么健康和快乐，她把我拉到一边对我说，我永远无法感谢你当初跟我进行那次对话并做出改变。它让俱乐部变得更好，也改变了我的人生。这对我来说
to me. Wow, that's an amazing story, Allison. And it's really testament to what happens when we handle difficult conversations well, that there is a huge payoff here, a huge psychological payoff here. Yeah. And don't get me wrong, it was scary to have that conversation. It felt like she didn't like the students. She was mad at us all the time.
意义重大。哇，这是一个了不起的故事，艾莉森。这确实证明了当我们妥善处理困难对话时会发生什么，这里有着巨大的回报，巨大的心理回报。是的。别误会我，进行那次对话确实很吓人。感觉她不喜欢学生。她一直对我们很生气。
We were always in trouble. And there was so much historical animosity that I was trying to sort of undo and shake up. And it took a lot of chutzpahs, or a lot of courage to go in there and try and sort of work through it. It wasn't easy. One of the incredibly difficult
我们总是惹麻烦。有太多历史积怨是我试图去化解和打破的。走进去并试着去解决它需要极大的勇气或胆量。这并不容易。你所做的那些极其困难
and incredibly powerful things that you did was that you apologized to her for the way that she had been treated in the past. And I think for people who are, who feel like they have been wronged or people who are in opposition, there's often a sense of, you know, sort of burning injustice. You know, I'm just an administrator. I'm here trying to keep the students safe.
且极其有力的事情之一，就是为她过去所受到的待遇向她道歉。我认为对于那些觉得自己受到不公对待的人，或者处于对立面的人来说，往往有一种燃烧的不公正感。你知道，我只是一名行政人员。我在这里是为了保护学生的安全。
You know, all they have is ill will toward me. They treat me so badly. No one recognizes what I've done. And so you have this narrative in your head of all the ways in which the world has been unkind to you. And of course the world doesn't constantly come and admit that. But when someone actually walks in the door and says, I'm sorry, it has a transformative effect on you. Can you talk a little bit about the power of apologies in the course of having difficult conversations? I think as a conversation researcher, as a human being,
你知道，他们对我的只有恶意。他们对我的态度太恶劣了。没有人认可我所做的一切。所以你的脑海中会有一个剧本，记录着世界对你不友好的种种方式。当然，世界不会总是跑来承认这一点。但当真的有人走进门来说“对不起”时，它会产生一种变革性的效果。你能谈谈在进行困难对话的过程中，道歉的力量吗？我认为作为一个对话研究者，作为一个普通人，
apologies are one of the most powerful tools we have in our conversational toolkit. They are so remarkably powerful. And they're quick, right? Like it doesn't take that many turns of a conversation to deliver an apology. And they're just, they can do so much good. It doesn't take that many turns of a conversation to deliver an apology. And they're just, they can do so much good.
道歉是我们对话工具箱中最强大的工具之一。它们具有惊人的力量。而且它们很快，对吧？比如，发表一个道歉并不需要花费太多对话的回合。它们可以带来极大的善意。发表一个道歉并不需要花费太多对话的回合。它们可以带来极大的善意。
And even though they're so powerful, many people are reluctant to give them. Talk a little bit about that. Why do you think that is, Allison? Given how powerful they are, why are we so reluctant to deploy them? Apologizing requires that you make yourself vulnerable to the other person. It feels like it requires you to humble yourself. It can feel like you are admitting that you were wrong in some way. And it makes yourself vulnerable to the other person because they could exploit that and
尽管它们力量强大，但许多人还是不愿意说出口。谈谈这一点吧。艾莉森，你认为这是为什么？鉴于它们如此强大，为什么我们如此不愿意使用它们？道歉需要你在另一个人面前变得脆弱。这感觉像是需要你放低姿态。这可能让你觉得你是在某种程度上承认自己错了。这会让你在另一个人面前变得脆弱，因为他们可能会利用这一点并
say, oh, yes, you were wrong. I was right. And that just takes an incredible amount of humility. But in practice, when you go through with it and you apologize, it doesn't necessarily equate to an admission of blameworthiness. It just feels so good for the other person to be on the receiving end of it that it makes the conversation and the relationship so much better. I want you to tell me the story of when your son Kevin was a toddler.
说：“哦，是的，你错了。我是对的。”这确实需要极其巨大的谦逊。但实际上，当你真正去做了并向人道歉时，这并不一定等同于承认自己有罪。对于接受道歉的另一个人来说，这种感觉实在是太美好了，以至于它让对话和关系变得好得多。我想请你讲讲你儿子凯文还在蹒跚学步时的故事。
I understand to the extent that he could talk, you had a series of very difficult conversations. Tell me how those went and what happened, Alison. Oh, my sweet Kevin. So Kevin's nine now, but back when he was a terrific kid, back when he was a toddler, he was a late talker. He was really frustrated and he had so many big ideas and he couldn't express them.
据我所知，在他还勉强能说话的时候，你们有过一系列非常艰难的对话。艾莉森，给我们讲讲那些对话是怎么进行的，发生了什么。噢，我可爱的凯文。所以凯文现在九岁了，但回想他还是个极好的孩子时，当他还是个学步幼儿时，他是个说话晚的孩子。他真的很沮丧，他有很多宏大的想法，却无法表达出来。
And so he would get really angry and mad and yell and scream and sort of flop around. And one day during one of these sort of tantrums, he reared his head back and he sort of butted his head right into my face and he broke my nose. And it was so painful, and so physically painful of course, but also emotionally painful, like as a mother, how do I have this child who's capable of like hurting me in this way? And how do I teach him to not be this way? And I just remember I plopped him down and I ran over to the mirror to see if my face was okay.
因此他会变得非常愤怒、抓狂、大喊大叫并到处乱摔。有一天，在这样的一次发脾气过程中，他把头往后一仰，直接把头撞到了我的脸上，把我的鼻子撞断了。这太痛苦了，当然身体上非常痛苦，但情感上也同样痛苦，作为一个母亲，我怎么会有这样一个能够以这种方式伤害我的孩子？我又该如何教导他不要变成这样？我只记得我把他往地上一放，然后跑到镜子前看看我的脸有没有事。
And it was a really dramatic moment that it was really hard. And he was so young, it was hard to decide how to react in that moment. I understand that you came back to this incident some years later, Allison. Can you tell me what happened? That's right. It became infamous in our family, the nose-breaking incident with toddler Kevin. And so over time, he heard me and my husband talk about this moment. We told it to him as a story and, you know, he learned to talk, he learned to regulate
那是一个非常戏剧化且非常艰难的时刻。而且他当时那么小，很难决定在那种时刻该如何反应。艾莉森，我听说几年后你又重新提起了这件事。能告诉我发生了什么吗？是的。这件事在我们的家族中变得臭名昭著，也就是与幼儿凯文的断鼻事件。随着时间的推移，他听我和丈夫谈起过这个时刻。我们把它当作一个故事讲给他听，你知道的，他学会了说话，学会了调节
his emotions, and he sort of came to find this story intriguing. He couldn't believe that he would have behaved that way. And one night, he was probably seven or eight years old, and we were reading together. And he was reading one of his favorite books at the time, you know, Diary of a Wimpy Kid. A lot of kids love this series. And the main character in the story typically
自己的情绪，并且他开始觉得这个故事很引人入胜。他简直不敢相信自己以前会做出那种行为。一天晚上，他大概七八岁的时候，我们正坐在一起读书。当时他正在读他最喜欢的书之一，你知道的，就是《小屁孩日记》。很多孩子都喜欢这个系列。而书中的主角通常
can be sort of thoughtless and can be kind of cruel to his best friend. But there was a part of the book where Greg apologized to his best friend. And it was a rare moment. It was a very sort of kind moment for the character in the book. And in that moment, Kevin stopped reading and he looked up at me and he said, Mom, he said, yeah, he said, do you remember when I broke your nose when I was a toddler? And I said, oof, yes, I do remember, Kevin. I don't think I'll ever forget.
会被认为有些考虑不周，对他的死党也可能有点残酷。但书中有一部分是格雷格向他的死党道歉。这是一个罕见的时刻。对于书中的角色来说，这是一个非常善良的时刻。就在那一刻，凯文停下了阅读，抬起头看着我说：“妈妈，”他说，“对啊，”他说，“你还记得我学步时把你的鼻子撞断了吗？”我说：“噢，是的，我记得，凯文。我想我永远不会忘记。”
And he looked at me right in the eyes and he said, Mommy, I'm so sorry. So sorry that I did that to you. And my heart just sort of burst in the way that I had cried so much when he first had broken my nose now I was I was crying again, but this time's out of pride It was such a meaningful moment to see how he had grown from being miss toddler struggling so much with language and his emotions And in such a short time, maybe five years later was in this place or he was able to own that and apologize and empathize and recognize my pain was just incredible.
他直直地看着我的眼睛说：“妈妈，我真的很抱歉。真对不起我那样对你。”我的心瞬间融化了。就像当初他撞断我的鼻子时我曾哭得那么伤心一样，现在我又哭了，但这一次是出于骄傲。看到他是如何从一个在语言和情绪上苦苦挣扎的幼儿成长起来的，这是如此有意义的时刻。在这么短的时间内，大约五年后，他能够坦然承认这一点并进行道歉、共情，并认识到我的痛苦，这真是不可思议。
Allison Woodbrooks is a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School. She's the author of Talk, The Science of Conversation and The Art of Being Ourselves. Allison, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line conversation. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirrell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury.
艾莉森·伍德布鲁克斯是哈佛商学院的行为科学家。她是《谈话：对话的科学与成为自我的艺术》一书的作者。艾莉森，非常感谢你今天作客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。请发邮件至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。邮箱地址再重复一遍，是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。主题请填写“conversation”。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、莱恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. For more Hidden Brain, be sure to subscribe to our free newsletter. In each issue, we'll bring you more ideas about human behavior, plus a brain teaser and a moment of joy. You can sign up at news.hiddenbrain.org. That's n-e-w-s dot hiddenbrain dot org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。想要收听更多《隐藏的大脑》节目，请务必订阅我们的免费新闻通讯。在每期内容中，我们将为你带来更多关于人类行为的洞察，外加一个脑筋急转弯和一个快乐时刻。你可以在 news.hiddenbrain.org 注册。也就是 n-e-w-s 点 hiddenbrain 点 org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们回头见。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。